[Musique]
j'ai créé deux modèles de robes pour
l'exposition de norman rockwell
donc j'ai repris les grands lignes de
ses tableaux me basant sur les coloris
qui l'utilisaient
notamment le vert et le rouge il ya une
forme de
de légèreté dans ses tableaux un côté
enfantin des robes penser comme des
oeuvres d'art inspirées par cet adage
qui dit que la mode est un éternel
recommencement
elodie schmitt crée des vêtements pour
femmes élégant et originaux c'est ici
dans son atelier boutique de versailles
qu'elle imagine et réalise elle même
robe de mariée ou tenue de cérémonies
qui ont été passionnées par la mode les
vêtements le dessin et travail manuel
traitement général depuis l'âge de 7 ans
g
j'avais envie de créer des vêtements un
rêve devenu réalité après des études
d'arts appliqués et de costumière elodie
a lancé son entreprise de création de
vêtements sur mesure il y a trois ans
face au succès rencontré la jeune femme
de 28 ans a décidé d'élargir son offre
sa nouvelle marque at the line la ligne
c est une marque de prêt-à-porter de
robes de mariée de tenues de mariage
essentiellement mais il y aura toujours
cette partie sur mesure effectivement où
on va créer des pièces uniques des
matières nobles et un savoir faire qui
ont un coût minimum 500 euros pour une
robe simple pour alimenter le catalogue
shooting obligatoires cela fait un an
qu'elle collabore avec charlotte
aujourd'hui essayages de robes de
mariées tuer dit un petit peu ce que ce
que j'aimais dans ses modèles elle elle
m'a conseillé sur ce qu'il irait mieux
avec mon profil ma silhouette
la première impression c'est vraiment
con ce sens hyper bien dedans on n'aime
pas on n'est pas gêné on est comme dans
une robe de tous les jours des créations
qui seront présentés au public du 17 au
19 novembre lors de la cour des métiers
d'art à versailles la vente en ligne de
la marque à tallinn est prévue
prochainement